wie wirkt sich eine rein pflanzliche
ernährung auf unser körpergewicht aus
ein internationales forschungsteam hat
genau diese fragestellung genauer
untersuch zwar ist bekannt dass durch
vegane ernährung wenn man nicht darauf
achtet wichtige nahrungskonkurrenten
fehlen können aber laut der studie kann
eine vegane fettarme ernährung
tatsächlich gesund sein und man nimmt
auch noch dadurch ab klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und activity glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen ob man fleisch ist sich
vegetarisch oder vegan ernährt hat nicht
nur etwas mit moralischen werten zu tun
denn nicht nur das wohl der tiere leidet
unter dem massenhaften fleischkonsum
sondern auch das klima eine große studie
hat erst vor kurzem gezeigt dass die
fünf weltweit größten fleisch und
molkereien konzerne für mehr
treibhausgas emissionen verantwortlich
sind als jeweils einer der größten
ölkonzerne dieser welt wir hatten
darüber ausführlich berichtet klicks um
science-fiction
doch bei der entscheidung für oder gegen
eine bestimmte ernährung auch die vor
und nachteile für den eigenen körper
eine entscheidende rolle und hierzu gibt
es einen richtigen dschungel an studien
die es gar nicht so einfach machen sich
einen überblick zu verschaffen fachleute
weisen darauf hin dass bei einer reinen
veganen also pflanzlichen ernährung die
herausforderung besteht den körper mit
bestimmten nährstoffen zu versorgen
das ist also wichtig sich im vorfeld zu
informieren und beispielsweise reichlich
bösen früchte zu sich zu nehmen um den
körper mit eisen zu versorgen außerdem
lebensmittel mit zusätzlichen vitamin
b12 wie beispielsweise frühstücks
cerealien oder hefeextrakt aufstriche
die er sowieso
das vitamin b12 enthalten doch dieser
minimale aufwand lohnt sich wohl nicht
nur in hinblick auf das klima und unsere
umwelt sondern auch im hinblick auf
unsere eigene gesundheit eine studie die
jetzt auf der jahrestagung der european
association for the study of diabetes
vorgestellt wurde bestärkt dies das
forschungsteam ist von der organisation
mit der bezeichnung für siemens
committee for responsible medicine pcrm
mehrere tausend ärztin und ärzte haben
sich hier zusammengeschlossen und setzen
sich unter anderem für eine pflanzliche
ernährung ein zudem kümmern sie sich um
alternativen zu tierversuchen bei der
aktuellen studie hatten
ab 150 fettleibige und übergewichtige
erwachsene mitgemacht 16 wochen lang
ernährte sich die hälfte von ihnen vegan
und fettarm das ergebnis ist eindeutig
diese teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
hatten bei der abschließenden
untersuchung deutlich an gewicht
verloren zwei drittel des verlorenen
gewichts bestand dabei aus körperfett
das autorenteam schiebt dieses ergebnis
auf die veränderung im verdauungssystem
denn die untersuchung zeigten dass die
anzahl von gesunden darm bakterien bei
den veganern deutlich höher war als bei
den nicht veganern dies begünstigt laut
der fachleute aber nicht nur die
darmgesundheit selbst sondern schützt
auch vor anderen krankheiten wie etwa
diabetes dazu hanna khalifa
die an der studie beteiligt war eine
pflanzliche ernährung mit reichlich
ballaststoffen verändert die
zusammensetzung des damen mikrobizid
even indem sie die richtige art von
bakterien ernährt konkret geht es um die
darmbakterien mit der bezeichnung
bakteriums die vor allem bei den veganen
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmern zu
finden waren
diese werden oft auch als schlankmacher
bakterien bezeichnet da sie die
aufgenommene nahrung nicht besonders
fein säuberlich auf trennen ziehen sie
weniger kalorien aus der nahrung heraus
sie lieben ballaststoffreiche
lebensmittel wie vollkornprodukte obst
und gemüse und vermehren sich bei dieser
art von ernährung mit rasanter
geschwindigkeit ähnlich ist es mit der
bakterienarten namensvetter bakterium
braust sie auch diese leben von den
ballaststoffen die in pflanzlichen
produkten enthalten sind diese bakterien
sollen nicht nur vor darm erkrankungen
schützen sondern werden auch mit einer
gewichtsabnahme in verbindung gebracht
konkret sollen väter lee bakterium
pausentee die sogenannte in urin
empfindlichkeit verbessern
obwohl ihn handelt es sich um ein
ballaststoff der in bestimmten pflanzen
wie beispielsweise pastinaken
eingelagert wird im menschlichen körper
soll er eine gesunde darmflora fördern
und die verdauung aktivieren
die packen art fettzellen bakterium
posten ece ist somit wichtig für einen
gesunden stoffwechsel eine wichtige
voraussetzung für die gewichtsabnahme
und die reduzierung des körperfetts
weitere studien sollen jetzt folgen um
die fettarme vegane ernährung mit
weiteren ernährungsformen zu vergleichen
beispiel
also mit einer fettreichen veganen
ernährung aber auch mit der sogenannten
mediterranen ernährungsform mehr
schlaganfälle durch veganer und
vegetarische ernährung anklicken
anschauen und klicks um nature
abonnieren da gibt es noch weitaus mehr
videos rund um natur und umwelt also
unbedingt anschauen und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran